si un lion dévore quelqu'un voulant
fermer en lui disant de ne plus jamais
recommencer
sauf que dix ans après quand il ressort
que se passe-t-il ce ne sont pas tous
des animaux
je vous donne de la voix que ces
prédateurs ont dans la tête
celle qui dit tu dois le faire tu dois
le faire tu dois le faire c'est cuit
oui je vous et désarmez elle est
toujours là mais il vous sera impossible
d'avoir une érection
qu'est ce que vous avez fait signer ça
vous économies vont être divisés
reversés aux filles dont vous avez abusé
les personnes que je traque un vivent
dans le noir et je pouvais les voir très
clairement avant que tu arrives dans ma
vie
il s'est dégonflé je m'ennuie je vais
rentrer et où la jeune fille qui était
ici elle est déjà parti aidez nous à y
voir plus clair qui est cette jeune rom
pour un très grand danger maintenant là
tout de suite ils n'ont discuté et
d'équiper la jeune fille d'un traceur
gps et qu'il utilise comme appât il a
plusieurs traits de personnalité et
chacun d'entre eux à sa propre réalité
mais j'ignore s'il a conscience de leur
existence à mon avis se fiche de nous je
parais à piéger sa part à quoi il a vu
six de nos meilleurs hommes c'est pas
cher qui courent
une autre filiale espagnole a coffré il
est ici
il est venu chez moi c'est impossible
laissez-moi m'excuser pour toutes les
choses que j'ai feuilleté et ensuite je
vous dirai où se trouve la dernière
fille
[Musique]
quelqu'un est le ciment
[Applaudissements]
quand vous les aurez trouvé qu elle est
[Musique]
tic tac tic tac tac
tic tac alors c'est qui le plus malin
d'après vous
[Musique]